hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more
how are you guys doing you may have seen
the video that I done recently about a
week and a half ago or two weeks ago
about Joe Rogan and I gave him credit
actually I gave him credit for some of
his stances about the Palestine issue
especially when he had one Abu Martin on
and she was giving good you know
historical information and firsthand
accounts about the situation in Gaza and
I commended him for that actually
because it takes guts and it shows
independence of thought and a mind and
that he's not a money over morals
individual and I thought this individual
was independent until I saw the
following clip where he's being
manipulated by a Zionist what do you
think I'm Israel You're the Palestinians
in Gaza if everyone everyone of the
people in Gaza laid down the arms and
stopped attacking what would I Israel do
to you it's a good question nothing
they've tried it five different times
they literally like stop Israel has
never not one time in history initiated
any conflict every single one of those
things that you're pointing to is a
retaliatory attack by a terrorist
organization but if that if those if
that was switched where I Israel you
Hamas in Gaza I take all of my arms and
all of my protection and I laid them
down what would what would Hamas do they
would kill every single one of them
that's what they do that's that's what
they''re sworn to do that's that's the
their motto and the the the origin of
their existence all the way back to the
Grand Muti traveling to Hitler to ask
how do we solve the Jewish Problem Like
you want to follow from the Muslim
brother Hamas to the m to the Muslim
Brotherhood all the way back to the gram
Muti to muin and you see the origins of
like one thing which is how do I solve
the Jewish problem is to eradicate and
kill them that is what Hamas came from
not the Palestinians not those poor
people stuck in Gaza but in that problem
if all of Hamas just went away we would
have peace if they laid down their arms
and they stopped murdering innocent
civilians and raping women and killing
babies you would have peace if the other
side laid down their arms they would all
be murdered now I I think that this clip
is
laughable and only a person who is a
non-specialist or an ignoramus or
propagandist would consider this to be
factual information the first thing he
said is that Israel never initiated any
kind of conflict well think of the
following before 1948 where was Israel
anyway Israel was not an entity so how
did it come to be an entity do you think
that Israel or the zionists in what
would then be called Israel were able to
establish for themselves a state without
conflict do you think that do you think
that's what
happened well if you do think that then
you're more ignorant than you sound
because actually if you read any book
any book even those from the secondary
source materials of Zionist
historians what you've said is actually
false on so many different grounds just
a quick one in the 1920s and 30s what
happened is that Jewish immigration to
Palestine increased in the 40s it
increased more rapidly and
exponentially and at the same time what
you had was the rise of Zionist militia
terrorist groups like iRun and Levy and
the stern gang I'll give you one event
that took place which was actually not a
reaction to anything but in fact a
terrorist attack which everybody who's
read on this issue knows about and that
is the 1946 King David Hotel bombing in
which 91 people died in fact white
people British people and this was
something which was initiated by those
groups now those groups or at least the
command ERS of those groups became Prime
Ministers and presidents of the unit of
Israel thereafter in 1948 when the
Inception of Israel took place and the
nakba took place as well in fact in 1947
what is referred to as the Civil War the
Palestinian Civil War where even in
hagana records which was one of the
groups the armed Jewish groups or
Zionist groups Ben Goran writes very
freely and honestly about the fact that
plan dallot which was a plan that was
intended to try and H B effectively
displace Palestinian people from their
place took place and that was before the
Inception of the state of Israel so now
we talk about
1947 and 1946 1947 before the Inception
of the state of Israel but even that is
just one aspect we're talking about the
one analysis another analysis is after
the Inception of the state of Israel you
see even the 1948 war that took place
between the Arab Nations around Israel
where by the way the people were
outgunned the Arabs were outgunned and
outmanned people think that this was so
many different countries versus Israel
no they were out gunned and outmanned
even in that war okay which they lost
which was a failure for the Arab Nations
it was a failure it was preceded by the
events aforementioned the nakba the pl
dalot the 1947 Palestinian conflict the
1946 King David Hotel bombing and other
things as well so what you're saying is
factually incorrect according to
everybody I mean nobody even from the
Zionist historian side says what you're
saying then you have the 1956 sez Canal
Crisis now there's no credible historian
that says that the sews Canal Crisis
which took place in Egypt a different
country a different Sovereign Nation was
because of Egyptian antagonism to Israel
this is not what happened in fact in
1956 SE War crisis sus Canal Crisis was
a conglomerate or an alliance between
Israel France and the United Kingdom all
three of these nations attacked Egypt so
you cannot say that this was an attack
on Israel by gal ABD Nas the then
president of Egypt which then led to
some kind of reaction no Israel along
with the United Kingdom and France
initiated the conflict and anyone who
knows anything about history knows that
there was then a UN resolution which
ended the conflict which by the way the
United States spearheaded this is just
go anywhere read any any book of History
man's field horor anyone you like and
you'll see that this is
mentioned then comes the 1967 war 1967
war was a surprise attack on Egypt and
Syria and Jordan it was a surprise
attack by the Israelis so how can this
be if it's a surprise attack which
destroyed so many different
infrastructure and it was a Six Day War
and you have military commanders of
Israel gloating and boasting about the
success of this surprise preemptive
strike they called it how could this be
because of some kind of an aggression
you are a liar and Joe Rogan should be
ashamed of himself for listening to
someone like you without factchecking
that
information I find that to be completely
objectionable why couldn't he use the
same rigor and integrity that he does
with the Mixed Martial Arts which is a
much lesser situation on a situation
like this if someone came to you Joe
Rogan and started talking rubbish about
Brazilian jiujitsu or about boxing or
about kickboxing or about Wing Chong or
about those things you'd be the first to
put them on the back foot and tell them
that they're the ones who are bsing you
you'd be the first to do we've seen that
we have seen that take place we've seen
you put people in their place because of
their lack of knowledge on Combat Sports
so where do you find the audacity or the
confidence to listen to a Zionist
manipulator manipulate you on key facts
which across the board Palestinian
historians Western
historians nonpartisan historians and
Zionist historians all
agree
so I think this is nonsense and I could
go further I could talk about
2006 I could talk about when Israel went
into the goolan heights I can talk about
South Lebanon I can talk about so many
different things I could talk about the
attacks from the Israeli Defense Force
on the gazan population which I've done
just recently recently which was on the
back of a great March in Gaza no one
shot a bullet and and no one fired a
rocket yet the IDF attacked them and
killed them the civilians so what you're
talking about is a lie how dare you
think you can lie on public in public
like this on social media and think you
will not be corrected and how dare
anybody on such a sensitive topic not do
the factchecking that is required then
he said in the other aspect or the other
par portion of the video he mentioned
the grand Muti of Jerusalem at the time
who went and saw the Nazis but did you
know that the same Zionist terrorist
organizations yes Zionist terrorist
organizations were the state of Israel
with the Inception of the state of
Israel they went and they also made
collaborations with the Nazis and this
is in peer rreview journals which I can
show you a picture of right now on the
screen you can go ahead and look at this
the secret Alliance that took place
between some of those terrorist
organizations Zionist terrorist
organizations and the Nazis themselves
why do you think that these Zionist
separatists
wanted to speak to the Nazis in that
manner because they both had a common
goal which was removing the Jews from
Europe and putting them or placing them
in Palestine so it showed you that even
those in individuals operated you're
mentioning the Muti the grand Muti am
husseini you mention him you don't even
know his
name
yes am husseini but you don't mention
the fact that the Zionist groups had the
same kind of logic or pragmatic um kind
of way of dealing with the matter with
the Enemy of the enemy is my
friend and then you ask a hypothetical
question what would happen if Hamas laid
down its weapons sorry if uh if all the
Jews laid down their weapons what would
Hamas do to them he said he would kill
them all but okay Hamas was elected in
2006 disengagement from the Gaza Strip
was in 2005 but Hamas was was incepted
in two in
1987 which means that there were
elements of Hamas in the Gaza Strip
where there were people who are settlers
and Jewish at the same same time so why
did if if what you're saying is true
then why didn't Hamas skill those guys
it's more than I don't know dozens of
settlements that took were there in Gaza
Strip why weren't they killed this is a
question that could be asked and if
everything has to go down to Hamas then
what happened before Hamas in 1987 are
you telling me when you had the secular
nationalist PLO and there was no such
thing as Hamas that the zionists were
not calling the secular nationalist PLO
terrorists they were call calling them
terrorists at that time as well so don't
make this into scapegoating Hamas and
for all your problems as if Israel is a
completely innocent party and then he
mentions as many people do that Hamas
has in its Charter that they want to
eradicate people in Israel or all the
Jews in Israel I actually went and
looked at some of the Articles of that
Charter to see if this is true now once
again we don't endorse or have a
membership card or whatever it is with
Hamas and we account Hamas as people
have seen
but truth must be told and
misinformation is misinformation if you
look at article 31 of the charter of the
Hamas Charter he said there's a
possibility it's possible it said in the
in the charter it says possible for Jews
Christians and Muslims to coexist in
peace and in quietude or something to
that effect so it's not exactly true
that it says explicitly that all the
Jews must be eradicated I've looked at
the charter that's misinformation
frankly and if that is what they say
then we oppose that as Muslim people and
if that is what they espouse that we
oppose that even if they don't espouse
it and if they act upon that we oppose
that we have no problem taking anybody
to account which is something you have a
problem with because you can't even
bring yourself to condemn the killing of
these people and then the man went on I
don't know what this guy is called to Jo
the manipulate I'm just call him the
manipulator the weasel manipulator the
coward the
liar the spouse of
misinformation The non-sp Specialist the
academic failure the ultra cedarian the
weasel and he said to Joe
Rogan that he was talking about the
hospital and he said that these
hospitals and and that was
misinformation why is it misinformation
and then Joe Rogan was jumping on the
bandwaggon and said that yeah the
hospital and the hospital okay for the
sake of
argument we don't we don't concede this
point to you we think that the most
intelligible and the most proper
explanation for the destruction of that
hospital was actually a big missile from
the IDF and you can see what the channel
4 has said about that you can see their
report in your own time they got a a
fantastic report disputing or refuting I
should repudiating the claims of the
zionists who say that this was a
misfiring of one of the Islamic Jihad or
Hamas that's one thing but what about
the refugee camp which houses tens of
thousands of people
the
jabalia refugee camp which the IDF took
full responsibility for they knew this
was civilians here and they they shot it
down they they B blew it up effectively
so even if you don't want to accept the
hospital then you have the refugee camp
don't try
it and Joe Rogan watch yourself with all
du respect don't mess about because if
this happened on American ground you'd
be the first one to show outrage and
condemnation we all know that
yeah do your fact checking because don't
make us angry don't make us upset don't
make us disappointed don't make us
disappointed yeah with your nonsense and
apply the same rigor apply the same
academic rigor that you
put to UFC fighting and boxing and mu
Tha to something much more important
quite frankly which is
one of the most important conflicts in
the world today with that I
conclude the prophet Muhammad s wasam
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in jenah and we know the great
reward that will not only be gained but
rather will fill your grave after your
death whenever someone prays there
whenever someone gives shahada in the
Masid whenever someone learns something
in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale